jess recently started a business
producing cosmetic products made from
natural ingredients
she wants to advertise her products by
distributing bags of samples in her
neighborhood
she calculated that it takes her two
minutes to prepare each bag
how many hours hours is interesting they
give us minutes here now they want hours
how many hours will it take to prepare
1200 bags of samples if she asks seven
friends to help her
with her work
so one thing we can think about is how
long would it take her to do it by
herself so it takes it takes her by
herself two minutes
two minutes per bag
and then we have 1200 bags
1200 bags not 12 bags 1200 bags
bags
which means it's going to take her 2
minutes per 12 for each of the 1200 bags
well that's 2 times 1200 is 2400
2400 minutes now that's if she was just
working on it by herself but she's got
seven friends and we can assume that
they all would all take about two
minutes to prepare each bag
now this is a little bit tricky because
you might want to divide this by seven
saying hey we we're going to have seven
times as many people but you remember
she asks seven friends so there's
actually eight people involved there's
jess and her seven friends so it's
actually going to be eight times faster
than if jess did it by herself so we're
going to divide this is if you only had
one person if you're going to have eight
people you are going to take eight times
less time
so with eight people it's going to be 2
400 divided by 8 is 300
300 minutes and we're almost done except
for the fact that they asked for our
answer in terms of hours
so 300 minutes is how many hours
well you have 60 minutes per hour so you
could say 300
minutes i'll just write min for short
divided by 60
minutes
per hour gives us 300 divided by 60 is
five
five hours so it will take jess and her
seven friends a total of eight people
five hours to prepare all of her her
sample bags